[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants cadeddu fait
aujourd'hui vous avez préparé des
déguisements
oh c'est une très bonne idée oui mais
pourquoi voyons une niche c'est pour
mardi gras
mais c'est vrai je vais oublier
je me demande si mirabel et p'tit louis
y ont pensé
je m'en vais voir ça de plus près vous
mais dépêche toi gros heureux mais ne
traîne pas comme d'habitude nos veuves
nom me propose
[Musique]
spitz
oui oui oui je peux pour passer
tranquille
attention à mes plus minime ans mais
pourquoi c'est faire toutes ses plumes
c'est pour mardi gras
je m'habille en indien et moi en gitane
quatre grosses mousse l'appel d'un thé
noir que je vais mettre sur mes cheveux
et le bouquet
je trouve pas que ce sera joli os ou moi
ben moi je rêverais chapeau d'un bien
quand c'est difficile à fabriquer tu
sais là on pique les plumes comme ça là
la nôtre ici encore comme ça comme ça là
oui j'aurais aussi des boucles
d'oreilles encore une vie sinon toujours
bien que nos pensées voilà la cua
[Musique]
pendant ce temps qui craint les plumes
attaque là oui on est dans le trop chaud
je suis brûlé tu vas cruz ou vers le bas
je préfère aujourd'hui c'est joli c'est
peut-être que ça m'irait aux longs repas
style oui oui c'est vrai il est très
tard
allons c'est assez pour aujourd'hui vous
finirez demain matin au lit ou à la
presqu'île oui ouais
[Musique]
et toi nos commandes il sera délivré
c'est un secret vous verrez ce que vous
verrez bien plutôt le plus vite possible
bonne nuit des enfants bonne nuit une
annonce qui lui pose ni robben temps
bien
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit indien
bonne nuit petite gitane bonne nuit les
petits enfants je suis sûr que demain
vous aurez tous deux très beaux
déguisements
allons allons de l'ours en route
toi aussi tu dois préparer ton costume
au port sûr que je dois le préparer je
leur ai promis
embrassez vos parents heureux et allez
vite vous coucher bonne nuit à demain à
demain
bon
[Musique]